- Having @tyler works with the ladies.
True or false, Tyler?
- [Tyler] True!
- I knew it!
Yeah!
- Yeah!
- [Gary] You've got your perspective.
(hip hop music)
(cheering)
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
(jazzy hip hop music)
We'll do it like 7pm,
we'll go until three in
the morning if I have to.
You get to hang right here with us,
Twitch studio building,
music going.
September 24th,
lock it in, just block it right now.
September 24th's gonna be the date.
See ya.
(hip hop music)
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 294
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
This is an exciting episode for me,
as you can see I'm
perched outside my office.
I have a small group of friends here.
We did a really fun barter party
for the Clouds And Dirt.
(hip hop music)
- Your grand plan to buy the New York Jets
is to buy brands, grow them
and then flip them.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] What is your criteria
for buying these brands?
- Opportunity costs, meaning,
I'm gonna wait 'til the economy collapses.
- Okay.
- And I'm gonna bottom feed.
Just all off the bottom
- Yeah.
I think the world's gonna melt.
- Yes.
- In the next two to seven years.
Who knows when,
if I did I would trade that way.
And hopefully I'll be
in a financial position
which is how I'm dealing with
cash and investment and VaynerMedia
to buy something that today
would cost me $330 million,
and I could buy it for 27.
A lot of youngster
you're a young dude
- Yeah.
- A lot of people don't realize
how bad it gets when
shit really hits the fan.
- Okay.
- Again, it's been a great economy now
for nine years.
So for a lot of people under,
you know,
if you're under 32,
if you're 32 and under,
you don't even know what
real life looks like
in a bad economy.
And even if you're 35,
you were still kinda young,
and you were probably 22, 23, 24
so you weren't affected
so you almost have to be
40, today,
to even have a good contextual concept
of what happens.
Minimally you gotta be 32
'cause you remember it
was hard to get a job.
- [Interviewer] Yes.
- So,
yeah I mean,
I don't think people understand
that everybody's gonna go out of business.
(laughs)
- Just gonna buy,
how many companies do you think you'll
- I only wanna buy one,
if you noticed the numbers I threw out,
it's not like I want to buy
a bunch of things for a million,
I want to buy Twix.
I want to buy K-Swiss.
I want to buy
Panasonic, whatever it may be.
Captain Crunch.
- Big legacy brands, that's your
- I like nostalgia, 'cause I think
I just said those things
and everybody listening is like,
oh I know that, oh I know that,
versus, I'm gonna start
Freshy-Fresh Cereal.
There's so much money in the nostalgia
of that kind of brand awareness.
I mean look what I'm doing.
I've been spending,
been bleeding my face off
to create brand awareness.
And still 99 percent of America
doesn't know who I am.
Yet 99 percent of America
knows exactly what Cap'n Crunch is.
- If a business, small or large,
was wanting to buy an Instagram account,
to be a marketing arm for them,
how would you recommend
them going about doing that?
- Finding the account and
the name that they like,
and DM'ing the person and saying,
"how much do you want for this account?"
- Just straight up
- Straight up.
- Outreach.
- Like if you're an ice cream store,
and you've got nine
locations in Baltimore,
the first thing I do is
go check out ice cream.
The account ice cream.
Which will be expensive.
But some people own names,
somebody hit me up the other day
and was like,
'yo my friend owns this account',
and I think it was like three letters
that made a word.
And they're like,
and they're being offered $400,000
for the Instagram account.
I'm like, 'sell it, and sell it now.'
(chuckle)
Because I know you can buy good names
for $10,000.
So you'd never know.
That was the extreme one way,
you might hit up ice cream
and it might be some kid who's like,
'5,000 bucks!'
You never know.
- Okay.
So just, top down outreach
okay.
So, this
- Tyler!
Get Tyler real quick.
While you're talk
I'm gonna find out
how much Tyler's been offered for
Tyler owns @tyler
- Okay!
- On Instagram.
- Ah, that's good.
- And I'm curious while
we're doing this episode
if I can find out from him
- [Interviewer] I'd love
to know the actual prices.
- Yeah I wonder,
hey Ty?
Have you been,
I love this podcast,
sorry everybody listening to the podcast,
have you ever been offered
an actual number for @tyler?
An actual number.
Not theory.
- [Tyler] Yes.
- How much?
- [Tyler] $50,000.
- Cool.
You passed, huh?
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- [Male] You passed.
Okay.
What
- I think he passed because I think
having @tyler works with the ladies.
And I think that
(laughs)
for me, it's a leverage
in society and culture
that he doesn't want to give up.
Tyler, true or false?
- [Tyler] Uh...
- True or false, Tyler?
- [Tyler] True!
- I knew it!
I knew it, I knew it, I knew it!
The end!
(hip hop music)
Here's what I would tell you.
The one thing you have to
give a lot of thought
to think about is
the market that you play in is volatile.
When the economy collapses,
people are gonna get smoked out,
and so you just need to be
really thoughtful as you make your content
to talk about the downside.
'Cause a lot of this stuff works
when the economy's good.
- [Male] Yeah.
- So just be thoughtful that
you're overcommunicating,
like, yo, homies,
this is right now,
but don't over-leverage yourself
'cause you're gonna get fuckin' caught.
Do you know what's gonna happen
when the shit hits the fan?
Everybody's gonna be like,
'Gary V said it!'
(hip hop music)
People are so focused on the negativities
of social and digital
without realizing how
much positivity there is.
- [Female] Just in the sheer access
of free information.
- Correct.
Positive information.
- Right.
- You find what you're looking for.
You wanna get sad?
Go read all the racist, #metoo,
Russia, hacking, negative stuff.
It's there, unlimited.
You wanna be happy?
Go find all the obnoxious amounts
of free content around
happiness, self-fulfillment,
positivity, it's all there.
You find what you're looking for.
Listen,
I realize it.
Everyone's always like,
'Gary, you don't even know'.
I'm like, I fuckin' know.
I'm not gonna talk about it every day,
it's a little obnoxious but
I realize it more than anybody
will ever realize.
I know exactly how this
fucking game is being played,
what's happening, who's getting impacted,
why, the scale of it,
and God willing,
if I'm able to stay healthy
and not have anything terrible happen,
I can leave a real fuckin' footprint.
(hip hop music)
I think audio is super important.
- [Male] Audio?
- Yeah, like I would,
couldn't push you enough to consider
as you're doing video
to convert it into audio podcasts.
I think audio's a big space.
- [Male] Okay, cool.
- That stands out.
Audio is something that
you can be first.
Shonduras popped because
he moved on Snapchat first.
- [Male] Yeah.
- First mover matters,
so being a leader in audio
or fuckin' with audio.
- [Male] Okay.
That's a good
- [Gary] And collabbing.
I would fucking go on your Instagram
and search your zipcode or your town
and just see what's popping
and see somebody who's winning
and it's like,
a funny guy, a model, a sports guy,
just DM'ing people and be like,
'yo, you want to jam?'
Couldn't believe,
people are the ROI.
Big.
(hip hop music)
Oh, these!
(laughs)
This, you're gonna,
this is very smart, my friend.
You're gonna make real
money on this one day!
(laughs)
Smart, wow.
I'm even starting to buy these!
I'm buying them!
- [Male] Really?
- 'Cause I can't get 'em anymore!
(hip hop music)
Be thoughtful of where technology stops
and where accountability ends, right?
- I'm trying to build a tool
so that people can leverage that
- Tools, I'm telling you,
'cause I've been through it,
tools are gonna disappoint you
if you don't have the right people.
There's two things.
If you're trying to build a SaaS product,
or an app,
that's a whole different story than if
you're building something internal
for your team.
- I'm trying to build it
to solve my team and then
if it helps other people
- I think that's an interesting
way to go.
I understand.
- [Male] Just helps me.
- [Gary] I got it.
You build something for yourself,
and then, wow, if we can scale it, wow.
I get it.
In watching a lot of things,
casting has been the bigger issue
and way to fix things for people
than utilities.
Not reinventing
what a football team does,
just getting a better quarterback
and left tackle.
- Oh, okay.
- Not creating some new scheme
that has never been invented,
run the ball on every play.
Flea flickers on every third play.
Not that.
It's, replace your right guard.
- Hmm, I see what you're saying.
- And so, it's something worth debating,
'cause what it will do, if nothing else,
what I'm excited about
when you leave right now,
I'm hoping that this energy
will run through your mind,
so that when you look at something,
you're like, is this a utility thing,
or a casting thing?
- The whole reason I legitimately put
your shoes on
(audio distorts)
and did a bunch of flips
out of the plane
was because that was exactly the activity
that resonates very strongly with my
impetus to start my company,
was overcoming fear, destroying anxiety,
taking the right steps,
which include throwing
myself out of a plane.
(hip hop music)